so uh for my talk of the table
um we're talking with a Hollywood
Powerhouse and I truly do mean that Judd
apatel he was one of the producers
behind the new movie Bros which stars
Billy Eichner it's the first ever gay
rom-com movie made by a major Hollywood
studio apatel is also the creative force
behind films like Bridesmaids classic
knocked up classic and the 40 year old
version classic classic classic that's
what he does in this clip eichner's
character Bobby is texting Aaron a guy
that he likes
honestly I was impressed you may be more
emotionally unavailable than I am well
maybe we can be emotionally unavailable
together maybe we can be emotionally
unavailable together who's writing your
texts Maroon 5
kidding we can go out are you asking me
out I'm down for whatever yeah same cool
sounds good so tomorrow or we can do
whatever yeah I can do whenever and I
can do whatever I don't care what we do
yeah me neither we can do whatever and
we can do it whenever does that work for
you yeah that definitely works great
Whatever Whenever cool Whatever Whenever
GIF of Michael Scott dancing that's good
office gift this person isn't gay
[Laughter]
joins us right now what's up bro good
morning I'm just trying to be in the
pocket I just needed my whole life or
like what the simplest dance advice
that's gonna be is that's it you got to
feel tight keeping it tight he's moving
along I cannot look around dancing
anymore please so let's talk about this
movie it's the first gay rom-com film
made by Major Hollywood studio
um what does it mean to be part of
something historic like this uh you know
when something like this starts you know
it's just I want to work with Billy
Eichner you know Nick Stoller wrote it
with Billy agner and he directed it he
directed Forgetting Sarah Marshall and
they came to me and I just thought well
it would be amazing work with Billy
because he's so hilarious and later when
it's kind of done people say oh it's
kind of a big deal they don't make
movies like this and so I'm very happy
that we're getting it out there you know
it says something that a studio wanted
to get behind it right it doesn't say
they wanted to make history it says they
wanted to make money and they think they
can so something has changed culturally
I mean you think the public is ready for
this this is the time for this movie it
didn't happen 30 years ago for a reason
right well you know we you know you test
these these movies you bring them around
the country to see if people get the
jokes and they like the movie and people
just went crazy for it I mean it's
really hilarious very like sweet and
romantic but the vibe I got from the
crowd was we were ready for this a
really long time right this took way too
long to happen and there should be way
more movies like me yeah no and it's not
just like rewriting the script from what
you know heterosexual rom-com would be
it's like it's very intentional and
methodical if anyone has friends who
date yeah in the scene the head of the
lgbtq community you know it ain't like
what yeah us folk do well I think that
uh you know the key for Billy was just
to make it really authentic right to his
experience but I think the old dating is
just a disaster
I think it's just always like you know
it's funny and awkward and it's you know
it's hard to find love it's hard to find
connection yeah so people all you know
relate to these stories yeah the movie
shows differences but also the parallels
exactly dating relationships
um this this film has almost every
character in it every actor
um part of the LGBT club lgbtq plus
Community
um why was it important to have that
type of representation in this film
uh I think that you know early in the
process Billy just thought let's let's
have every single person acting in the
movie be from the lgbtq plus community
and part of it is because there's so
many talented people that don't get
opportunities so we talk a lot you know
about how many people we love that are
so riotously funny yeah and and you see
them and you wish there was more to you
know go online and see all their stuff
but they have been denied opportunities
yeah and they're amazing yeah uh you've
got a lot of great movies out there uh
if I wanted to watch everything you've
ever done yeah I did some calculations
this morning I'd have to subscribe to at
least seven maybe eight different
streaming services yeah it's complicated
it's you know this is what they need to
figure out because it's like 15 bucks a
service and you need like six seven
eight and I often wish that they were
all connected in some way like a channel
like
connected with a cable maybe you pay one
person yeah
you can tell it's gonna all reform like
I was like trying to figure out where my
stuff was because you know it's I'm here
I could plug like if you want to see the
bubble yeah Netflix okay if you want to
see uh exactly Anchorman 2 Amazon
Anchorman one Paramount plus yeah
I love it good for getting some Marshall
for getting Sarah Marshall is on 2B
and then funny people peacock they're
everywhere they're everywhere much for
people we have to say congratulations on
both your Emmy for George Collins
American Dream oh it's great uh which
which is yeah which is a documentary but
I have to say so much would you say were
you influenced by him and and what you
do and what you and how you do it well I
think if you know if you love comedy as
a little kid and you watched a lot of
George Carlin I think it like he
programmed your brain to be a critical
thinker because that's really what he
was all about was taking a really hard
look at things and and challenging
Authority he used to say
parents don't teach uh their kids to
challenge authority because their
Authority so you don't want your kids to
challenge you but you really want uh
people especially now to look at what's
going on and get educated you know he
always says like we get the politicians
we deserve you know you have to really
yeah pay attention yeah that's not a
very flattering bit for the American
election and it was a very intimate look
at Carl and especially later in his life
fantastic it really was well done I have
to say thank you too for bringing this
important work Bros in a fight it's very
fun very funny oh thank you go see it
yeah yeah that's the most important
thing I mean I think we all need a
comedy in a theater just watching it
with like a lot of people is so fun we
we all need that big laughs nothing like
a good comedy Judd Apatow thank you so
much we appreciate you bros hits
theaters on Friday September 30th